[Música]
el expresidente peruano Alejandro Toledo
llegó a la cárcel de barbadillo donde
cumplirá 18 meses de prisión preventiva
por el momento sin recibir visitas la
justicia peruana la o acusa de recibir
sobornos millonarios de la constructora
brasileña odebrecht
miles de migrantes partieron en una
nueva caravana desde el sur de México
hacia la capital de ese país los
migrantes piden la eliminación del
Instituto Nacional de Migración y de los
centros de detenciones todo A poco de
cumplirse un mes del incendio que se
cobró la vida de 40 personas en Ciudad
Juárez
este 25 de abril inicia en Bogotá la
Cumbre internacional sobre Venezuela un
encuentro auspiciado por el presidente
de Colombia Gustavo Petro que tiene como
fin destrabar las negociaciones entre el
oficialismo y una parte de la oposición
tenemos análisis
Bienvenidos a este informativo con las
noticias más relevantes del continente
americano soy Valentina Torres Sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos comenzamos en
Perú porque el expresidente Alejandro
Toledo llegó a la cárcel de barbadillo
en Lima la capital allí cumplirá los 18
meses de prisión preventiva el ex jefe
de estado que lideró el país entre 2001
y 2006 fue extraditado desde Estados
Unidos donde residía tras haberse
entregado a las autoridades se le acusa
de haber recibido millonarios sobornos
de la constructora brasileña odebrecht
Alejandro Toledo ya está en barbadillo
el expresidente de Perú fue recluido en
la cárcel en la que también se
encuentran los ex mandatarios Alberto
fujimori y Pedro Castillo allí deberá
permanecer 18 meses en prisión
preventiva la cárcel fue la última
parada de una movida jornada antes
Toledo se presentó a una audiencia de
verificación de identidad
Alejandro Toledo manrique toreo llegó a
su país de origen extraditado desde Los
Ángeles Estados Unidos después de
entregarse las autoridades peruanas
venían pidiendo el procedimiento desde
2018 el ex mandatario es acusado de
haber recibido 35 millones de dólares en
sobornos de la empresa brasileña
odebrecht a cambio de favorecerla para
construir la ruta interoceánica Sur que
conecta Perú con Brasil los cargos que
recaen sobre el mandatario son tráfico
de influencias y lavado de activos y
probar que Alejandro Toledo y todos los
funcionarios y las
en la capital peruana algunos seguidores
le manifestaron su apoyo a quien fue su
jefe de estado entre 2001 y 2006
nosotros
queremos para Alejandro Toledo Toledo se
convirtió en el segundo expresidente
extraditado después de que fujimori lo
fuera desde chile el ex mandatario niega
las acusaciones y sus abogados y
familiares habían pedido un arresto
domiciliario debido a su estado de salud
tengo entendido que los médicos
en Estados Unidos ya han dado un informe
que él padece de Cáncer y tienen que
hacer un chequeo minuciosos no la
tradición Toledo pidió la justicia
peruana que no lo dejen morir en una
cárcel continuamos en México donde una
nueva caravana migrante partió desde
Tapachula en la frontera con Guatemala
hacia Ciudad de México en esta ocasión
Los Caminantes no solo intentan alcanzar
el llamado sueño americano sino que
también denuncian la precaria situación
de los migrantes en México exigieron
además justicia por los 40 migrantes
muertos en un incendio en Ciudad Juárez
el mes pasado
un nuevo viacrucis con rumbo al norte de
llegar a Estados Unidos para darle todo
a mí Unos 3000 migrantes en su mayoría
venezolanos partieron de las ureña
ciudad de Tapachula fronteriza con
Guatemala hacia la Ciudad de México allí
intentarán acelerar los trámites de su
solicitudes de asilo en Estados Unidos
Los Caminantes esperan llegar en unos 10
días a la capital mexicana pues adelante
nada de rendirnos A dónde quiere llegar
usted Patricia pues alto a lo que Todos
queremos hasta los Estados Unidos luchar
y luchar para un mejor futuro para mi
niña Hay una que dejé allá en Honduras
también los integrantes de la Caravana
también están exigiendo justicia por los
40 migrantes muertos en el incendio de
un puesto de detención en Ciudad Juárez
el pasado 27 de marzo estamos
protestando por las cuarenta muertes de
Ciudad Juárez para que se hagan los
institutos de migración para que el
presidente Obrador mire que realmente es
una buena causa que estudian al director
de migración porque son estos son los
campos de concentración en los búnkeres
de este siglo en este sentido un jefe
Regional de la autoridad migratoria
Mexicana fue detenido y acusado de
presunto homicidio por el siniestro de
Ciudad Juárez El funcionario
identificado como Salvador González
dirigía el Instituto Nacional de
Migración en el estado de Chihuahua se
espera que la Caravana llegue hasta la
Basílica de la Virgen de Guadalupe
según la agencia de protección de
fronteras y aduana de Estados Unidos en
el año fiscal 2023 más de un millón 200
migrantes llegaron a la zona limítrofe
en el año fiscal 2022 esa cifra superó
las dos billones 300.000 personas
en Ecuador la decisión del presidente
Guillermo lasso de autorizar el porte de
armas a civiles divide a la población
mientras unos se han inclinado por tomar
clases de tiro para aprender a
manejarlas otros aseguran que ampliar la
circulación de armas generará todavía
más violencia nuestro corresponsal en
Quito Gustavo Ortega nos cuenta la
historia
Patricio Barragán comenzó a asistir a
prácticas Se tiró al blanco el
incremento de la criminalidad en Ecuador
y la nueva ley que permite el porte de
armas lo ha motivado a entrenarse para
estar preparado ante un eventual suceso
que ponga en riesgo su vida yo espero
nunca estar en medio de algún
algún alguno de esos eventos Pero bueno
entre todo eso prepararse no está de más
perfecto Te felicito José bastidas es un
experto en el manejo de armas tras la
medida decretada por el ejecutivo
ecuatoriano recibe centenares de
llamadas de nuevos aspirantes que
quieren aprender a disparar el decreto
exige contar con 25 años de edad no
tener antecedentes penales y denuncias
por violencia familiar y justificar la
tenencia de un arma Entonces esto
realmente ha motivado a las personas
pero también con esto la delincuencia
también va a poner en alerta
no solo los civiles están tomando la
iniciativa de Aprender a usar armas Los
vigilantes de seguridad como Miguel
también deben tener una preparación en
uso de armamento porque según la medida
gubernamental ahora serán apoyo de la
Policía Nacional si usted no utiliza
alarma le pueden salir como Cómplices no
sino que queda como un guarda ya en
epecto que no no pudo hacer bien su
trabajo algo y si lo utilizamos Claro
que tenemos podemos enfrentar cargos con
la justicia
preocupa el psiquia Fernando Cornejo en
experto asegura que los Ecuatorianos
sufren de paranoia ante el estado de
inseguridad y armarlos generaría más
violencia si se enfrentan a una eventual
reacción en defensa personal vamos a
llamarle porque es una conducta desde
adaptativa en general de la población y
esto nos puede llevar a que no tengamos
los filtros suficientes para poder
generar una situación de defensa datos
oficiales señala que en el año 2021 se
produjeron 1081
en el año 2022 se incrementó a 2.521 y
los tres primeros meses de 2023 la
Policía Nacional ya lleva contabilizadas
1356 asesinatos Este martes 25 de abril
inicia en Bogotá la Cumbre sobre
Venezuela en la que se prevé la
presencia de representantes de al menos
20 países el objetivo del presidente de
Colombia Gustavo Petro es destrabar las
conversaciones entre el oficialismo y
parte de la oposición de hecho la semana
pasada se reunió en Washington con el
presidente Joe biden para discutir un
eventual levantamiento de sanciones
previamente conversamos Con Román Ibarra
abogado y especialista en gobierno y
políticas públicas que nos explicó si es
factible que el encuentro permita
asentar las bases para un acuerdo que
lleve a elecciones libres en Venezuela
bueno el panorama es ciertamente difícil
pero el solo hecho de que haya
conversaciones para tratar de destrabar
el hecho de las sanciones que tanto daño
han producido a la comunidad venezolana
a la ciudadanía común y no al gobierno
Porque al fin y al cabo el venezolano
común es el que sufre los embates de la
de la escasez de Electricidad de la
imposibilidad de invertir en el sector
eléctrico o en el hidrológico entre
otros sectores entonces lleva como
consecuencia que las sanciones afectan
fundamentalmente a la ciudadanía común y
no al gobierno cualquier negociación que
apunte a destrabar estas sanciones y
auspicie mecanismos según los cuales
pueda haber más libertad más democracia
y nos aproximemos a unas elecciones cada
vez con mejores condiciones Siempre será
bienvenido además también es notorio el
hecho de que los Estados Unidos van a
participar en esa conferencia lo cual le
da una amplitud mayor también en los
Estados Unidos le conviene qué tanto en
Colombia como en Venezuela haya paz
estos mecanismos de entendimiento van a
producir Dios quiera unos avances en el
caso venezolano y Dios quiera que
también algunos avances en Colombia
porque la paz de Colombia y la paz de
Venezuela convienen a ambos países pero
también a los Estados Unidos que siendo
socios hemisféricos deberían estar
interesados en que Venezuela y Colombia
marchen juntos en acuerdo con las
políticas norteamericanas y no lanzar
los embarazos de China y de Rusia que es
el peligro más latente que tenemos hoy
por hoy fin del informativo volvemos en
breve
[Música]